I
one necessity truly is in self
consciousness is for this new form of
self consciousness in which it knows its
own self to be the principle of
necessity it knows that it has the
universal of law immediately within
itself and because the law is
immediately present in the being for
self of consciousness it is called the
law of the heart this form takes itself
to be quoi individuality essence like
the previous form but the new form is
Richard because it's being for itself
has were at the character of necessity
or universality
with paragraph 367 we've now reached
another important transition point in
the phenomenology we're moving into this
this section called the law of the heart
and the frenzy of self-conceit vons in
could also mean something like insanity
the insanity of self-conceit the stress
here in these these first paragraphs is
going to be on the law of the heart and
and what this means before I talk about
that and before we go into that that
particular paragraph let's think for a
moment about where this fits into the
phenomenology and what we've traversed
so we just finished up with the very
short section pleasure and necessity and
you see here you know pleasure on one
side necessity on the other that is what
has been left behind but remember that
when we're leaving something behind
we're never truly leaving it behind in
the Hegelian dialectic we are as we move
to another shape a gestalt of
consciousness our hey bong that is
however you want to translate sub
elation transcendence takes place and
what that does is that brings along
somewhat of what was surpassed so there
is an integrative function there's a
moving on having learned certain lessons
and remember too that some actual self
consciousness is within history or the
ones who are silly and I'll sort of
replicating these dynamics in the
present may in fact be stuck in a
previous stage of the dialectic and
never really get out of it they never
have the realization so pleasure a
necessity the law of the heart and then
the section that's going to follow it
virtue in the way of the world are all
part of this shorter middle section of
the reasons section the actualization of
self-consciousness or if we want the
longer title the actualization of
rational self consciousness self
consciousness that is reason through its
own
tivity let's remind ourselves as well
that self-consciousness once it became
liberated from what Hagel was calling
ethical substance once it liberated is
perhaps too strong of a term once it had
broken itself free of the sway of laws
and mores and customs and you know
everybody having their they're sort of
determinate place within the organic
community and it became an individual in
a stronger sense now it began looking
for its own happiness its own gluc right
and the question is well what what does
happiness actually consistent now what's
particularly interesting about this
section as opposed to previous
treatments of happiness is that Hagel is
is treating this in a distinctively
modern way he really is engaging in a
phenomenology he is looking at the
phenomena of modern ethical life and and
by ethical life we mean this is seeking
out of what is meaningful what is what
is going to provide us with happiness
another way of saying it is what is
essential to the human being qua human
being and not everybody is able to do
this of course this is this is something
that you might say is in large respect
the privilege the shape that we're
looking at here the privilege of either
an elite few who have the resources to
be able to have these sorts of mindsets
or those who arrive at the point where
they have nothing to lose because what
we're talking about here according to
huegel and and many of his commentators
is a distinctively modern way of
understanding oneself as an individual
through practical life this notion of
the law of the heart within oneself it's
not the voice of God it's not the you
know voice of society
the logos or however you want to put it
it is the human heart and it's its
sentimentality revealing new principles
to us about how we ought to behave so
who does Hagel have in mind in thinking
about this sort of stuff well among
philosophers I think that we could say
for example Rousseau although there were
many other philosophers along this this
line as well we're so is just somebody
who we still read today in drama in
literature there's other people as well
who are going to assume an important
role in this and we generally class them
under this rubric of Romanticism now
when we talk about being romantic today
we have this rather superficial notion
of what it means to be romantic as a
matter of fact we think of it primarily
when we say romantic we think erotic
right except sort of a sublimated
eroticism but what they had in mind was
a way of getting towards something that
was deeper something we would discover
within our own hearts our emotions our
passions and it was supposed to as well
see it as we get to later paragraph it
was supposed to be leaving us to a
higher state of being a better way of
developing self-consciousness something
that would in fact hopefully re rework
the the you know alienated society and
bring about some sort of reconciliation
although a sentimental rather than a
strictly rational reconciliation so all
of that is very important to keep in
mind as we move into this this section
so Hagel talks about this is being a new
shape of consciousness and he says what
necessity truly is in self consciousness
it is for this new form this new Gestalt
of self consciousness in which it knows
its own self to be the principle of
necessity so what we had going on in the
past
dialectic was the the individual person
is seeking taking enjoying pleasure but
we saw that that actually led away from
pleasure as being any sort of
realization and it led ultimately to
something that was unsatisfying which is
necessity or fate and Hagel said this is
understood is a great unknown as a
working that actually crushes the
individual and this is a universal now
these end up sort of being taken out of
the picture and being brought under the
rubric of self-consciousness and the
necessity is now placed within
self-consciousness now why well from a
phenomenological perspective remember
that whenever there's some sort of
alienation that's happening think back
to the the unhappy consciousness as a
prime example is some something is
projected out there is the universe and
I'm the lowly individual in relation to
it I'm just a particular I'm not worthy
that's where the real action the
essentiality is happening well I'm the
one who's thinking that that exists as
such for me because I am consciousness
so a similar reincorporation happens at
the beginning of this when so Hagel says
it knows that it has the universal not
just the universal in terms of essence
or what it is to be a human but the
universal of law of Gazette's and how
does this have it it has it immediately
within itself because he says the law is
immediately present in the being for
self of self-consciousness what does it
mean to be self conscious it means to be
not only being in itself but to be being
for oneself to be aware of oneself
including the distance that this
produces from oneself the fact that one
cannot be reduced to merely one's
characteristics or or a story about
oneself or any sort of objective thing
like that because there's a dynamism
there right there's a reflexivity so in
this stage it's not aware of this in
terms of a concept it's in terms of the
heart and the heart is you know we
talked about the heart in many different
ways you know metaphorically it's sort
of the locus of love and love is very
important love is a from a Hegelian
perspective a passion a sentiment a
feeling food right and so much of what
is going to happen with this is the
individuality finds within itself new
principles even a law but it's going to
be expressed in terms of something that
is very individuated which is feeling
not something conceptual that can
include everybody else that's going to
be the big problem with this but at
first this seems quite promising I look
within myself and I find a law how do I
know that law is there I feel it it
convinces me I I know for example I see
suffering humanity and my heart responds
and I know what the right thing to do is
and I'm no longer so alienated as I was
encountering just blind necessity
telling me hey you know your pleasure
it's happening within the wheels of this
necessity it's going to break your
pleasure into nothing right I feel like
I matter more like my existence like I
my life my action my feelings my fine
thoughts matter more as a matter of fact
they are expressive of law that is
bringing together what is finest in
humanity I'm no longer just grubbing
after tawdry pleasures I'm about what
what life is really for so he says this
form takes itself to be qua
individuality essence
like the previous form but the new form
there's something going on here it is as
he says richer because it's being for
self has the character of necessity or
universality it's been taken back into
it necessity universality now fall
within the province of the individual
this looks very very promising indeed
the law therefore which is immediately
self-consciousness azone law or a heart
which however has within it a law is the
end which self-consciousness proceeds to
realize we have to see whether its
realization corresponds to this notion
and whether in that realization it will
find that this its law is its essential
nature
this short paragraph number 368 is not
developing very much but it is setting
our problem into view that we're going
to be grappling with in the paragraphs
you have to come so what we've got here
are a number of different terms we've
got self-consciousness and the heart
which are really the same thing but
self-consciousness is understanding
itself as the heart or understanding the
heart as what is most essential in it
and then we have the low ah the
Gazette's right of the heart but it's a
law in general and there's some sort of
end at sveck a goal a purpose and Hagel
will also talk in terms of realization
and the contrast between the realization
and this notion now we should understand
as we always do notion can mean more
than one thing here we take it as sort
of the notion in the impoverished sense
a mere idea this idea of the law
something that's being you know
experienced and lived out and practiced
and then the notion in the sense of that
which is bringing all these things
together and is not just the thing
that's being compared but the comparison
or the action of comparison to this end
so there's a lot actually going on in
here but like I said this is not
actually resolving anything this is
setting the problem so he says the law
which is immediately self-consciousness
is oh ma or a heart which however has
within it a law so the law belongs to
self consciousness or the heart it's
coming out of them in some sense other
the question where it actually comes
from isn't resolved at this point but he
says it the law is the end that's vac
the goal and this can be understood in
terms of sort of an ideal that's that's
attempted to be put into to practice or
measured up to right but it can also be
understood in terms of its fairview
click on its realization it's being made
actual how does it pan out
when you follow out the urgings of your
heart does it turn out the way that it
should that provides us with the real
measure right so you feel a sense of
sympathy with people you act on that
does it actually produce good effects
for them and for yourself or does it
make things worse in the process that is
the end that's the fear clicking that
shows it you know what what's actually
going on so he says we have to see
whether its realization corresponds to
this notion and whether in that
realization it will find that this its
law is its essential nature so it's it's
not yet up you know we could say it at
this point it's actually up for debate
whether it's going to pan out or not and
he hasn't yet produced what ideally it
looks like or feels like or sounds like
it ought to be producing so we don't
know at this point whether the law of
the heart is just a kind of mistake or a
trap or a dialectical divergence or
whether we're directing ourselves
towards some sort of higher-end some
sort of greater purpose some sort of
better more essential way of being that
we have to find out by actually trying
to actualize it to realize it
this heart is confronted by a real world
for in the heart the law is in the first
place only for its own self it is not
yet realized and is therefore at the
same time something other than what the
notion is this other is thereby
characterized as a reality which is the
opposite of what is to be realized and
consequently is the contradiction of the
law and the individuality this reality
is therefore on the one hand a law by
which the particular individuality is a
press to violet ordering of the world
which contradicts the law of the heart
and on the other hand if humanity's
suffering under that ordering a humanity
that does not follow the law of the
heart but is subjected to an alien
necessity it is evident that this real
world which appears over against the
present form of consciousness is nothing
else but the foregoing discordant
relationship of individuality and it's
truth the relationship of a cruel
necessity by which the former is
oppressed for us the preceding movement
appears to stand over against the new
form because the latter in itself has
resulted from it at the moment from
which it has come is therefore necessary
for it but to the new form that moment
appears is something already given since
it is not conscious of its origin and it
holds that it's essential nature is
rather to be for its own self or the
negative element relatively to this
positive in itself
here now in paragraph 369 we arrive at a
first we might call it schema ties ation
of the law of the heart and the way in
which it works it has a correlative term
which is going to be the world or the
other to it and at times that's going to
be understood as is it's called here
sort of an alien necessity and external
reality but but this is also a reality
of other people of other individuals of
other self consciousnesses and that's
going to raise some really interesting
problems in the course of this study
because what we've got going on at first
is a person who says I I have a law
within my heart that I can follow that I
need to realize now where can it be
realized well it can be realized in
terms of oneself with a kind of
circularity that the for itself gives
but as we've seen over and over and over
again throughout the phenomenology it's
not a realization unless it happens
outside of the sphere of your own
self-consciousness there is no you no
possibility of you might see a
narcissistic satisfaction in hegel
instead it has to be engaging with what
we're translating here according to
Miller as the real world or the German
for it is vir Clea cat actuality
something that is different than that is
other than the self conscious individual
so this law of the heart calls out to be
realized out there in the social world
that includes other human beings and
here's where we're going to start
running into some issues the other thing
that I want to point out is really
coming towards the the end of this this
paragraph Hagel is pointing out a sort
of forgetting a lack of realizing its
own origins that's involved in any
sort of similar romanticism or
sentimentality that involves this law of
the heart so he says the for us the
preceding movement appears to stand over
against the new form because the latter
in itself is resulted from it and the
moment from which it has come is
therefore necessary for it that's what
we can say as the phenomenologist who's
studying this right and if we're
thinking about particular individuals we
might talk about a person shifting out
of this this original phase of their
life where they're just sort of seeking
pleasure in an individualistic way and
they run into so alien necessity and now
they they arrive at this law of the
heart but then they forget about the
past they don't acknowledge it so he
says to the new form that moment appears
as something already given the law of
the heart within oneself in opposition
to the world is something that's just
there I just happen to have found it I
maybe I didn't know it before but now
that I'm conscious of it it's always
been there you know my yearning to help
humanity by going off and doing mission
work of this sort or my yearning to
right all the wrongs on the internet by
the way I comment on things showing what
a swell guy I am you know so enlightened
so right thinking so whatever it happens
to be whatever values we're standing for
so he says it appears that something
already given since it is not conscious
of its own origin and it holds that its
essential nature is rather to be for its
own self or the negative element
relatively to the positive in itself the
positive in itself is the world that
it's confronting and to skip ahead a
little bit what's it going to say about
the world the world is screwed up it's
my job to make it better to fix it to
bring something good into it to whether
it's you know planting flowers somewhere
or helping the the impoverished or you
know counseling somebody who's who's
feeling blue
whatever we're going to talk about you
making wonderful music that that uplifts
people all this could be expressions of
the law of the heart as Hagel's talking
about it so let's go now to what he says
at the beginning he says the heart is
confronted by a real world for in the
heart the law is in the first place only
for its own self it is not yet realized
that has not reached at vac that end
that we talked about in the previous
paragraph and therefore at the same time
something other than what the notion is
its notion hasn't been realized so it
says this other what does the other is
thereby characterized as a reality which
is the opposite of what is to be
realized so where do you realize the law
of the heart in the external reality and
why do you realize it there because the
external reality screwed up it's not the
way it should be the law of the heart is
supposed to provide us with a new way of
being a new ordering so he says what
we've got here is a contradiction of the
law and the individuality that's what
this this world is it contradicts the
law of the heart within says this is the
way things are ordered the hagel uses
term or denying there a little bit later
and so we've got the way the world is
structured the way the world is set up
which is cruel which is unfair which
does not satisfy not only are our you
know sort of primitive desires for
pleasure but also our are you know
sentiment for something better for self
respect for people being treated fairly
for people getting their Just Desserts
if you're a villain you should be
treated like a villain if you're a hero
like a hero if you're a victim we should
defend you you know go on and on and on
we should heal the wounded and so forth
so he says we have a contradiction there
this reality he says is therefore on the
one hand a law by which the particular
individuality is oppressed so there's a
law in the heart which at this point is
not yet effective and then there's a
of the world which he at this point
expresses it as an order and ordinal and
this ordering you know violent goodell
tiga ordering of the world it
contradicts the law of the heart and
then he says on the other hand what we
have is a humanity suffering under this
particular ordering so we have the
individual and then we have humanity
sort of writ large and what we don't
actually see is of course that humanity
is in Harry whole world but the
sentimentalist you know sees that you
know the victims as something different
than the oppressive power structure or
we know however we want to talk about it
he let it later he's going to talk about
you know the priests and the tyrants and
all that that's coming straight from
Rousseau basically so he goes on and he
says a humanity that does not follow the
law of the heart but is subjected to an
alien necessity so we've got three terms
here now we've got the individual who is
following the law of the heart that's
where self consciousness is developing
we have the you know the bastards who
are pushing everybody down and following
the way in which they think the world
has to go and it's just terrible you
know powers and principalities and
there's no good reason for what they're
doing but there is an ordering and then
there's a humanity that suffers under
this order because they don't realize
what the law of the heart says about
them so perhaps you know they they all
you know buy into the profit motive and
they're all trying to screw each other
over making each other miserable in the
process and none of them are getting
ahead like those fat cats on the top of
the pyramid here we can go on and on
with all sorts of other examples of this
so he goes on and he says it's evident
this real world which appears over
against the present form of
consciousness is nothing else but the
foregoing discordant relationship of
individuality and truth the relationship
of a cruel necessity by which the former
is oppressed what is he talking about
there we already went through something
like this in the pleasure
and necessity dialectic but the person
who is now captivated by the law the
heart forgets about that as we said
earlier in this and we have a new
beginning in terms of this law of the
heart and what it can possibly be
applied to so now we need to see where
we're going to go from here and how this
opposition is going to play itself out
you